Putin refusing to help the
private army, the Wagner group,
that's according to the chief of
Wagner tonight claiming the
Kremlin will not take his calls
anymore.
>> Translator: To get me to stop
asking for ammunition, all the
hot lines to offices, to
departments, et cetera, have
been cut off from me.
They've also blocked agencies
from making decisions.
>> It's pretty incredible, and
it could be significant because
the Wagner group of course is
responsible for the small
successes Putin has notched in
this war.
The U.N. Estimates at the start
of this year, there were about
50,000 Wagner groups fighting.
But they have been pleading,
pounding the table, for more
ammunition almost daily.
In fact, here they are over just
the past few days.
>> Translator: I'm knocking on
all doors, sounding the alarm
with ammunition and
reenforcements as well as
covering our flanks.
>> Translator: We are the
artillery unit.
Every day we cover assault
groups, at the moment, we are
completely cut off from the
ammunition supply.
>> Completely cut off.
This is all in just the past few
days.
Tonight, that big admission that
nobody seems to care.
No one is listening.
Because it does seem clear if
Putin wanted Wagner to remain a
priority, things would be
different.
Wouldn't be cut off from all the
phones.
Putin's regular military has
been complaining that too much
has gone to Wagner fighters
until now.
Here's a Russian soldier.
>> Translator: Now all the
ammunition is going to Wagner
pmc units who can fire a week's
worth of ammunition in a day,
which we can't afford.
>> So now, you hear it.
Russian versus Russian in a
battle for ammunition.
And it is a remarkable turn of
events, especially given that
right now, it is Wagner's flag
flying in eastern kakhmut, not
Russia's.
But the ammunition shortage may
explain why Putin started
something suddenly today,
launching what's been described
as one of his biggest air
assaults in months.
This is almost like a firework
there going up in the sky.
34 missiles were launched
overnight according to Ukraine.
Ukraine intercepted only 34.
At least 11 people have been
killed.
It hit a lot of infrastructure.
Power was knocked out in several
areas.
Tonight, Ukraine is bracing for
another attack.
Tonight, we're learning the
United States and its allies
have now blocked or seized more
than $58 billion from Russian
oligarchs.
That's a huge number, but it is
not a lot relative to how much
they have.
To really squeeze the Putin
insiders, there's much more
money out there.
According to Forbes, they have
83 billion.
And their collective worth,
again, not counting the
uncollected of Putin.
According to Forbes was about
$320 billion.
Alex, with that missile assault
across the country that you
heard and saw yourself, what is
the latest on the ground there?
>> Reporter: Well, Erin, here
where we are in the lviv region
where we saw the highest death
toll, five people killed, and we
are hearing tonight from
president zelenskyy speaking
about the power outages that
have resulted in the wake of
this strike, particularly around
the power plant which has been
occupied by Russian forces and
maintained by Ukrainian
staffers.
It's the biggest power plant in
Europe, and it went on to its
emergency backup generators.
Zelenskyy accusing them of
creating such physical
situations at our nuclear
facilities as to what Russia
calls a massive retaliation
strike.
Fire fighters frantically
looking for survivors as others
clear the debris from an
overnight missile strike in
Ukraine's lviv renal.
Falling fragments started a fire
that destroyed at least three
residential buildings and left
at least five people dead.
According to local authorities,
the residents were at home.
The victims of Russia's latest
terrorizing country wide missile
and drone attacks far from the
front lines.
This is horrible.
I don't know what to say, this
man said, calling Russians the
devil.
All across Ukraine, 84 missiles
were fired and eight drones
launched at ten different
regions from lviv in the west to
the south all the way to donetsk
in the east.
The capital of Kyiv, at least
three people were injured.
These cars burned out from more
burning fragments.
For the first time, Ukraine was
bombarded with many different
types of missiles, according to
a spokesman for the air force.
It was a range of cruise
missiles launched from the air
and area, including six
hypersonic missiles as well as
guided missiles.
All told at least 11 Ukrainians
were killed and more than 20
wounded.
On Facebook, president zelenskyy
calls Russia's strikes an
attempt to intimidate Ukrainians
again, returning to their
miserable tactics, the occupiers
can only terrorize.
That's all they can do, but it
won't help them.
Ukrainian officials describe the
wave of attacks as yet another
strike on the country's critical
infrastructure.
Power was affected, and the
power plant had to switch to
diesel generators.
34 missiles and half the drones
were shot down, but several of
the types of Russian missiles
fired can't be taken down with
Ukraine's current air defenses,
which the Biden administration
says they're working to bolster.
>> Certainly you see there is a
real air defense need, and
that's why we're trying to focus
on the kinds of air defense
capabilities that the Ukrainians
really could use to help knock
down some of these missiles, and
they were successful in knocking
down quite a few of these from
last night.
>> Reporter: Russia quickly
claimed responsibility, calling
the strikes massive retaliation
for an alleged cross border
attack in Russia last week by a
pro-ukraine group.
Two Russians were killed, they
said, but CNN has not confirmed
the events, which Putin called a
terrorist attack.
And tonight, Ukraine's energy
minister says they are working
to restore power fully.
He says they are making good
progress.
He praised the energy workers.
The power is restored in Kyiv,
but 1/3 of the homes are without
heat.
Of course, it's very cold here
in Ukraine in March.
This was, according to the same
minister, the 15th major strike
against Ukraine's energy
infrastructure, and he noted the
new tactics we saw from Russia
today, a combination of